à travers les époques les dangers quand
aventure les appels
on se retrouve chez auditeurs toujours à
la recherche du père d'iris nos trois
compagnons ton de plus tôt sur hitler
c'est vraiment pas lourd et j'ai comme
l'impression qu'il n'est pas du genre à
laisser passer des inconnus dans sa
bibliothèque personnelle c'est comme ça
les dictateurs n'aime pas être dérangé
tout le monde sait ça tient faites-vous
de ma bibliothèque dati est fou avec vos
costumes extravagants ses pattes et hugo
boss tout ça surtout la chute est très
courte maladie
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour quoi il parle
avec l'accent n'est pas censé tout
traduire si mais je trouve ça plus
marqué l'essai personnages meta
l'hexagone est un modèle de temps que
sur pied une équipe entière coûte
il en faut beaucoup pour gagner contre
staline et lé charme hurricanes et il
fait même le café
vous en voulez à réfléchir avec beaucoup
démené comme pas ces trous noirs aaa
après voilà le café vous allez voir
ceinture et qu'il sert un café à hitler
a que je ce qui fait au mieux je sais
qui c'est hitler suite bacon j'ai joué à
wolfenstein merci et puis il s'était
trouvé ton père et puis là il a fait
deux mâles n'y a rien fait mal
il n'a rien fait de mal maintenant tu
vas y la ville accueillant mais tu
parles de dictateurs qui déciment des
populations est ce qu'il faut faune et
des tirs vous parlez aux fumeurs une
écoute et une balle perdue qui
apprécieront 8 allons monsieur hitler
tout va bien on parlait de staline au
petit point sépare les bons je laisse
couler c'est bien parce que les
messieurs mais on fait un café on l'est
ca coute j'aime pas ça comme enjeu le
nous sauver la vie ça vous aussi vous
êtes là pour me prendre un livre de ma
collection personnelle commence à 1 1
messieurs en blouse blanche bas prix un
livre là juste avant que vous arriviez
mais comme c'était un carnet insipide
écrit par un juif chaude lui est honni
par dont vous savez où il est parti à
vous durban il a disparu sous messieurs
c'est probablement mais caporaux ssl qui
m'ont offert un petit spectacle syrie si
le carnet
le kernel vous pouvez nous en parler à
c'était un cadeau d'un de mes statuts
d'un carnet de notes d'un juif qui écrit
fait de la science c'était un certain
einstein ton père est venu chercher des
notes einstein c'est sûrement pour ses
recherches sur le temps thomas rassure
moi tu sais qui c'est einstein bien sûr
c'est le mec de l'expression je suis pas
einstein mwa jsui ouais c'est sûr que tu
es pas einstein toit ni où est ce qu'il
est allé mon père ensuite éclair peut
nous aider à savoir m at what are dolf
le monsieur à la blouse aurait pas parlé
d'une destination future
non non non juste avant de disparaître
et la direction 744 sur l'île de la
réunion
ce que ça peu fou c'était oui oui c'est
pas mal oui je vais ouvrir la fenêtre
j'ai effectivement un voyage du docteur
six mois cette période ont surement
accord parfait osé postaux mal son
époque et direction l'hymne de la
réunion n'ont pas encore non mais je
vous suis moi je peux je peux être super
utile regarder hitler a failli nous tuer
mais il nous a trouvé sympathique
grasset grâce à mon café c'était mon
idée iris 18 ch peu de super utile crise
il risque à ce que tu regardes bougies
pareil ça fait du bien et russe tu veux
te tuer claire thibout iata on se
téléporte avant qu'on aidé dans ma vie
risque vient de sauver le monde à tuer
père n'ont pas vraiment naze et plus
compliqué hitler est décédé s'est
terminée la guerre les morts est dans ce
monde là oui mais dans ton époque où
dans la mienne ça changeait rien v le
regard de thomas j'ai l'impression qu'il
n'a rien compris aux rage pas einstein
moi vos trucs de voyage dans le temps
les gens meurent les gens meurent pas tu
les aimes c'est qu'on peut changer de
temps mais aussi de monde il existe une
infinité de thomas comme une infinité de
heatley or regarde elliot on revient
quelques secondes plutôt stable
approchez-vous temporal isation
immédiate
regarde autre plus et au plus ça soulage
tu as compris vas-y à toi elliott en
arrière tu es quelqu'un dit ne sera mort
que dans ce monde ça n'a aucune
importance puisque c'est hitler
vas-y ça soulage son bouquet juste pour
voir monsieur hitler
ouais ça fait du bien
juba meurtrier non on s'en fout c'est le
voyage dans le temps violent encore une
fois stoppées
allez une dernière j'ai fait c'est
génial on a assez poussées hitler on
peut y aller laissez-moi venir avec vous
jusqu'à la prochaine destination
bon et tâche de rester en vie elliott
allons retrouver mon père approchez-vous
traces temporel synchronisée direction
c'est sous 44 sur l'île de la réunion
au tampon réalisation immédiate
le
se retrouver sur une île plus tôt là on
est dans une cabane qui donc on est dans
un bateau mais le voyage dans le temps
n'est pas parfaitement précis lille doit
être juste à côté
ça aurait pu être pire on aurait pu
tomber dans l'eau et mourir noyé très
rassurant et iliad merci beaucoup
bon on sort de là c'est fait comment ça
c'est fermé pourtant à ouais merde on
est enfermé et pourtant on est enfermés
dans les geôles des cas d'une frégate wa
autant mois du vocabulaire en fait ouais
c'est parce que j'ai joué à assassin's
creed black flag j'ai saigné le jeu est
né sont pas le cramer laissez-moi
utilisé mais capteurs olfactifs
oui ça sans cravate et c'est normal
regarder derrière les barreaux des
flammes le bâton et enfin du tout mais
la télé bordeaux hayart vous allez rien
mais avec votre est clair que vous avez
tué un paquet de fois je n'ai plus de
batterie pour voyager dans le temps est
ce que tu vois quelqu'un rire ici
j'aurais vraiment préféré at elle est
forte dans l'autre je prends note marc
nohr ne prend pas notre nom les clés je
vois les clés derrière les barreaux
propos du couloir 6 environ regarder
elliott a fait quelques [ __ ] un café
non mais le yacht avec deux sucres des
pétards vous servez à rien on va mourir
et c'est sûr vous suivre
très incisif comme encore un nouvel
endroit value qui ignore qu'elle est
derrière la grille à l'ena ou alors en
faire je sens les fleurs viterra que
vois-je mais vous êtes enfermé clergé
tous les clients rien et pourquoi
devrais-je faire ça d'amyris n'êtes vous
pas dans un endroit que vous méritez on
la connaît très mal et non écoutés nous
hérisse n'est absolument pas maléfique
l'occasion d'accéder à votre trône bas
s'est présentée à elle est ce que vous
aurez reculé à sa place non vous auriez
fait comme elle qu'est ce que vous a
coupé la tête non elle vous a gardé près
d'elle alors pardonnez la donne et nous
l'éclairer un événement
par pitié il commence à faire très chaud
mais un jeu vous donne les clés mais je
vous laisse à votre sort et je garde la
boîte mail fils arash merci à linars
merci thomas ses clés la cua les clés
non plus et elle est portée avec les
clés on est foutu tout d'abord elle
murmure qu'elle est sa raison que tout
vaut mourir nos chances de survie sont
proches de 1% niveau
françois lacan désolé c'était pour des
temps d'être qu'elles ont entendu une
chanson qui y at il des âmes à se courir
dans ce bateau en flammes
mon dieu j'arrive tout de suite qu'un
poids la lettre e pour cent n'ayez
crainte je vais ouvrir cette porte à
l'aide de ma force reculer vous je
prends un peu des landes
personne n'est blessé en acier vous nous
avez sauvé c'est normal je parcours
n'est terre et les maires pour secourir
les personnes en danger
vite sortons des six voilà qui a goûté à
match et j'en vois trois autres qui
veulent être découpée en morceaux par le
célébrissime pirates
pis ce qui est mieux être enfermé dans
un bateau feu où se retrouvaient face à
un pirate sanguinaire dans un bateau en
feu
pas besoin de choisir pour iris elliott
et thomas ce sera la hache du pirate
rendez vous au prochain épisode pour
savoir en combien de morceaux ils seront
découpées
merci d'avoir écouté le quatrième
épisode de l'épopée temporel n'hésite
pas à ta bonne et à mettre un pouce en
l'air et à la semaine prochaine